we're all islands shouting lies to each
other
across seas of misunderstanding
[Music]
if history were taught in the form of
stories
it would never be forgotten
a woman's guess
is much more accurate than a man's
certainty
[Music]
of all the liars in the world
sometimes the worst
are our own fears
a man can never have too much red wine
too many books
or too much ammunition
take everything you like seriously
except yourselves
[Music]
i keep six honest serving men
they taught me all i knew
their names were what and why
and when and how
and where and who
[Music]
no price is too high to pay for the
privilege of owning yourself
[Music]
you must learn to forgive a man when
he's in love
he's always a nuisance
gardens are not made by singing
oh how beautiful
and sitting in the shade
there is no sin so great as ignorance
remember this
the world is very lovely
and it's very horrible
and it doesn't care about your life or
mine or anything else
[Music]
we have 14 million reasons for failure
but not a single excuse
now
don't be angry after you've been afraid
that's the worst kind of cowardice
buy a pup and your money will buy love
unflinching
that cannot lie
the first condition of understanding a
foreign country
is to smell it
[Music]
how can you do anything
until you have seen everything
or as much as you can
he travels the fastest
who travels alone
the noblest form of fear known to people
is fear for the fate of another
[Music]
high feelings
are always dumb
the choice of adults can be as random as
the choice of toys by children
[Music]
create problems for yourself if it's
your nature
but don't create them for others
the glory of the garden lies in more
than meets the eye
there's no jealousy in the grave
excessive courtesy is sometimes no
better
than rudeness
there is no greater sin
than ignorance
if you can think
and not make thoughts your aim
more men are killed by overwork
than the importance of the world
justifies
it does not matter what people think of
a man after his death
at 20 the things for which one does not
care a damn should
properly
be many
[Music]
where does wisdom come from
if there is malice in the heart
[Music]
upbringing is the highest of blessings
but only when it is of the first grade
otherwise it is useless for anything
[Music]
learn first
teach later
[Music]
people in essence do not grow up they
only get old
[Music]
the only thing you will regret in old
age
is not doing it
the most stupid woman can cope with an
intelligent man
and only the most intelligent can deal
with the fool
[Music]
the man remembers three women
the first the last
and the one
better to be torn apart by beasts
than killed by people
[Music]
you